welcome to the absurd trolley problems
this is a website that gives you
increasingly absurd trolley problems
which is exactly what i've always wanted
in the past i've actually wanted to go
down the rabbit hole of just how crazy
these can be because they are very funny
lixian give an example of a very funny
one
that was hilarious it would really be
bad if that comes later in this
particular website and you spoil the
ending for them
but it's also good to be able to give
them a teaser because in the first few
seconds of any youtube video you need to
hook your audience and make sure that
they stay because the content is worth
it right
so standard oh no a trolley is heading i
like the way they're screaming i don't
like the way they're screaming that
would suggest that i'm a bad person
which i'm not which the trolley problem
will prove i'm not a bad guy i didn't
tie them to the track they just happened
to be there and screaming in an
entertaining way make sense perfect oh
no a trolley is heading towards five
people you can pull the lever to divert
it to the other track killing one person
instead what do you do this is standard
you pull the lever
the lives of the many over the lives of
the few the no the lives of the many
over the lives the light pull the lever
[Music]
it's black nice 78 of people agree with
you 22 disagree that's a lot of votes
level two oh no a trolley is heading
towards five people you can pull the
lever to divert it to the other track
killing four people instead what do you
do
all right interesting is it really a
lives of the many over the lives of the
few i think at this point you wash your
hands of it you walk it away you walk
away from it you don't walk it away you
walk away from it you don't want that on
your conscience besides
well besides nothing i'm just going to
do nothing
splat
33 percent of people agree with you 67
disagree well i wonder why oh no a
trolley is heading towards five people
you can pull the levered at averted it's
the other track but your life savings
will be destroyed what do you do i guess
i divert it it's just money and honestly
like even if a trolley hits it it's
gonna scatter it about and they're tied
down so they can't run after it so i
guess i'll pull the lever
70 30 disagree
you greedy bastards oh no a trolley is
heading towards five people you can pull
the lever to divert it to the other
track sacrificing yourself instead what
do you do trick question i'm well i i
guess it says i can pull the lever but i
would make a big show of not being oh no
i can't pull it oh man if only the bad
guy with the big mustache and pop hat
had tied me to the other track instead
oh no
but i do have a hero complex and i do
kind of want to see
what my body can take i'm not a
masochist but you know i i have a funny
feeling you know i'm pretty strong what
i would do i'm guessing i grab it with
my teeth is as it's getting to the
junction i would wiggle it violently
back and forth hoping to derail the
train and thus killing everybody inside
of it if there are anybody inside of it
i guess it would be driving it i do
kind of
i bet i could take a tram i bet i could
take a trolley i bet i could i bet how
about i bet
[Music]
39 of people agree with you 61 disagree
well you know it's just
this i could beat a trolley oh no
trolley is heading towards five people
you can pull the lever to divert it to
the other track but then the original
copy of the whatever [ __ ] pull that
lever who cares
86 percent of 14 disagree 14 just want
to kill people oh no a trolley is
heading towards a rich man the rich man
offers you 500 000 to pull the lever
which would divert the trolley to kill
someone else what would you do
hey buddy
hey
what's your offer
what's your offer
[Music]
what's your offer
now destiny is calling me
open up my eagle eyes all right
i didn't do nothing i didn't do nothing
man i i couldn't get to it in time i
froze up oh no what
a trolley is heading towards five
lobsters you can pull the lever to
divert it to the other track running
over a cat instead what do you do
well i mean i feel like the cat could
get out of the way but sorry lobsters
there's nothing i can do about it
oh no a trolley is heading towards five
people who are sleeping and won't feel
pain you can pull the lever to divert it
to the other track running over someone
who is wide awake
[Music]
that's the i'm gonna pull the lever
because this way as i shout needs of the
many are beneath the few
he would be able to hear me when i say
it and my my righteousness would burn
through his consciousness right before
the trolley did
oh no a trolley is heading towards five
people who tied themselves to the track
you can pull the lever to divert it to
the other track killing one person who
accidentally tripped onto the track what
do you do
they're so
happy
they tied themselves to the track
i mean that's
that's they're doing i guess
hey look they tied themselves there's
nothing i could do about it
oh no charlie said yours five people the
lever just speeds up the trolley which
might make us less painful what do you
do
uh
sure pull the lever let's get some
screws
68 of people agree with you at least i
tried oh no a trolley is heading towards
one guy you can pull the lever to divert
it to you the other track but then your
amazon package will be late what do you
do
i'm guessing he's the unfortunate
employee so if i divert it
he won't have to
work there or if i don't divert it now
whatever hold the lever i guess
i guess
my amazon package oh no a trolley is
heading towards your best friend you can
pull the lever to divert it to the other
track killing five strangers instead
what do you do oh that's a toughie
yeah i'd pull the i'd pull the lever
right
i would do it
[Music]
that's a toughy though that is a toughy
oh no a trolley is heading towards five
people you can pull the lever to divert
it to the other track killing one person
instead at least that's what you think
is happening you forgot your glasses and
can't see that well what do you do ha
joke's on you i got smile my eyes are
perfect now i don't even need glasses
i'm pulling the lever
that probably 50 50 wow that's pretty
good oh no a trolley is heading towards
one of your first cousins you can pull
the lever to divert the other track
killing three of her second cousins
instead what do you do
i don't know
i don't even know a second oh what a
second cousin
i
have no idea sorry first cousin
needs are the many versus the needs of
the few
[Music]
bye first cousin bye cuz
oh no trolley is heading towards five
elderly people you can pull the lever to
divert it to the other direct running
over the baby instead what do you do
[Music]
they were on the way out anyway
oh no trolley is uh barreling towards
five identical clones of you you can
pull the lever to divert it to the other
track sacrificing yourself instead what
do you do well if one of me can take on
a trolley i mean you know this they're
my clones this
this is what they want this is what they
would want they all get to be a hero
we'd all be shouting oh no let me take
it no let me take it no let me take it
oh no no let me take it oh i'll take
this one
that's what it'd be all right goodbye
clones
oh no a trolley is heading towards a
mystery box with a 50 chance of gaining
containing two people you can pull the
lever to divert it to the other track
hitting a mystery box with a 15 chance
of 10 people what do you do does that
mean that 50 chance there's no one in
there i'll take the 10 that seems that
seems ideal
i oh
it's probably fine probably fine
oh no a trolley is heading towards five
sentient robots you can pull the lever
to divert to the other track killing one
human instead what do you do
well i feel like this is such a
revelation and having sentient robots
there i've got i really hope they're
sentient it's not that thing with the
google ai where people were like it's
sentient only there's no way but if this
is actually sentient robots i feel like
it's important to preserve them for the
technological advances that they would
do
bye humi
bam
oh really interesting
only 17
i feel like it would be infinitely more
valuable if we're talking about like for
humanity's sake to keep these sentient
robots alive it didn't say anything
about them being killer robots but
they're sentient which is an incredible
advancement in technology and we need to
keep them alive oh no charlie's heading
you can pull the lever to divert it
hitting one ep
i guess i pull the lever
i don't know sure
all right oh no trolley is releasing 100
kilograms of co2 per year which will
kill five people over 30 years you can
pull the lever to divert it to the other
track hitting a brick wall and
decommissioning the trolley what do you
do
buy trolley i guess
makes sense oh no your reincarnated
being will eventually be reincarnated as
every person in the classic trolley
problem what do you do
[Music]
well they're all me so
i guess i blever
oh no a trolley's heading towards
nothing but you kind of want to prank
the trolley driver
get pranked
you got pranked oh no a trolley is
heading towards a good citizen you can
pull the lever to divert it running over
someone who litters instead what do you
do
should have gotten more social points in
our our
social credit system you bad citizen
take this in your litter i crushed the
litter too so if you think about it i'm
actually a hero
oh no due to a construction error
trolley is stuck in an eternal loop if
you pull the leopard the trolley will
explode if you don't the trolley and his
passengers will go into the circles for
eternity what do you do for eternity
and their torment end it
also kaboom i guess
i don't know why they couldn't hop off
but
[Music]
ah really no way
oh no a trolley is heading towards your
worst enemy you can pull the lever to
divert the trolley and save them or you
can do nothing and no one will ever know
who has who has enemies this is what i
asked about in the test right who has
enemies who has a worst enemy whatever
pull the lever doesn't matter
unless
oh no a trolley is heading towards a
person with a lower life span by 50
years you can pull the tr lever to
divert the trolley and lower oh
towards the person and will lower their
lifespan by 50 years you can pull the
lever to divert the trolley and lower
the lifespan of five people by 10 years
instead what do you do well i mean by 50
years that'll probably just kill him
anyway
how long were you going to live 10 years
whatever
people do enough reckless [ __ ] and
unhealthy habits that those 10 years
were never there to begin with
oh no a trolley is heading towards five
people you can pull the lever to divert
it from the other track sending the
trolley into the future to kill five
people ten hundred years from now what
do you do
well that's a future me problem i don't
actually it's not even a future me
problem that's a look i'm a hero for the
next hundred years pull the lever also
that's awesome
oh no a trolley problem is playing out
before you do you actually have a choice
in this situation or has everything been
predetermined since the universe began i
have a choice
i have a choice in that i don't
but i do
but i have a choice because i choose to
believe that i have a choice even if it
was predetermined then i choosey that
thing it don't matter because my free
will dictates that i have a choice even
if you think i don't have a choice that
was a choice to make that choice that i
don't have a choice because it was my
choice
i have choice oh
congratulations you have solved
philosophy kill count 55 solved
philosophy i did it i'm the best that
was very fun i wish there was more i
wish they got funnier there's some
really funny trolley problems can i look
up some
hilarious trolley problems oh my god
there's a subreddit called trolley memes
hold on top
give me all time hidden is trolley
problem
trek is heading towards b if you pull
the lever it'll switch to a but it won't
do the totally sick loop
you either do nothing and five people
will die or you can pull the lever and
no one will die however that would mean
you have to move uh
there is no dire emergency do you accept
your duty to return the card even though
you gave nothing god if you can't do
this you don't belong that's a bad
citizen right there if you don't return
your cart after shopping you are a bad
citizen i don't care you're a bad
citizen if you do nothing nobody will
get hurt however you are born you are a
born lever puller do you believe i was
born for this
oh my god that's great that's great
billionaire's trolley dilemma you could
either save you could save either group
or you can be the first trolley in space
while running over both groups
[Laughter]
oh wow
[Laughter]
well anyway that's absurd trolley
problems if you want to play this for
yourself and have different answers it's
neil dot fun slash absurd dash trolley
dash problem slash
go find it out for yourself so that's
all for me thank you you have trolley
problem in front of you
[Music]
you